Kuei, bienvenue à Parole autochtone,
ici c'est Melissa Mollen Dupuis.
Cette semaine, j'ai une question de Philippe
qui me pose une question que j'aime
particulièrement :  « Pouvez vous expliquer
la naissance du mouvement Idle No More
et les revendications de celui-ci? » Écoute Philippe,
là tu me fais plaisir, parce que Idle No More, pour moi,
ç'a quand même été un moment charnière dans ma vie.
Non seulement d'un point de vue personnel,
de vue personnel,
mais ç'a été aussi
aussi un moment révélateur
pour les femmes des Premières Nations
de reprendre un rôle de leadership
qui était un rôle traditionnel, celui
qu'on avait avant l'arrivée
des premiers Européens.
Quand le mouvement Idle No More
a commencé en 2012, ç'a commencé
avec un moment d'apprentissage qui s'appelle
un « teach in » qui était un atelier
d'apprentissage communautaire et populaire
et c'était pour parler des loi omnibus
qui allaient être créées et qui allaient enlever
des protections à l'eau. Et là, on se demandait
pourquoi on enlève des protections à l'eau.
Une des plus vielles lois fédérales
de protection des rivières,
de protection de l'eau qui va être enlevée.
Et comme les femmes autochtones,
on a un rôle traditionnel
de protéger l'eau, puisqu'on a une rivière
millénaire qui coule dans nos corps depuis
nos grands-mères, nos mères et moi,
jusqu'à ma fille, ce rôle de protectrice
de l'eau c'est une responsabilité
qu'on prend très sérieusement.
Et quand on a compris que la raison
pourquoi on enlevait des protections à l'eau,
c'était pour faciliter le passage
de pipelines à travers des territoires
des Premières Nations pour des pétroles
qui allaient être arrachés du sol,
qui allaient détruire le sol des communautés,
qui allait se faire aussi
au détriment de la santé des communautés.
Ça a créé un effet de dominos où
on a vu dans le fond l'enchaînement
des actions du gouvernement fédéral sur
les communautés, et pas seulement sur une
petite communauté dans un petit coin,
mais vraiment c'était un enchaînement
tentaculaire à travers le Canada
qui remontait dans le fond
jusqu'à la Loi sur les Indiens, les pensionnats,
le Sixties Scoop,
les femmes assassinées et disparues,
le manque de financement en éducation,
le manque de financement des langues,
le manque de protection de la sécurité
alimentaire dans les communautés éloignées.
Tout ça, issu du colonialisme.
Donc la mouvance Idle No More
a commencé grâce à la loi omnibus,
grâce à un « teach in », mais c'est quand
même une mobilisation qui existe
depuis le début de la colonisation.
Mais c'est un domino qui, maintenant,
a amené qu'il y a eu des changements énormes
par rapport à la pratique des gouvernements,
à la pratique des institutions,
à la pratique des médias. D'ailleurs, Espaces
autochtones en est un très beau résultat.
Mais, c'est dû à la mobilisation
des communautés autochtones
face à des lois ou à des pratiques qui sont injustes.
Donc, Idle No More, c'est se lever,
peu importe où tu trouves,
peu importe quelles sont tes allégeance,
mais c'est de te lever contre l'injustice,
contre la perte de droits
humains, contre la perte de territoires
qui va non seulement nuire
aux communautés autochtones,
mais aussi à la population canadienne.
Donc, merci pour la question et j'aurais
pu continuer pendant encore une heure,
mais je vous invite justement à nous en poser d'autres,
à nous les envoyer à Espaces autochtones
et à Parole autochtone,
et n'hésitez pas à partager les vidéos.
Je vous souhaite
une très belle semaine.